you guys that group number was
phenomenal
i think that when the leader leads the
group to first overall that's huge thank
you you're welcome kyra runs to the
occasion thank you for giving me the
opportunity she proved she's a leader
and
nailed her performance and killed it and
now we need to take this and keep going
up
i feel like you guys all know what's
coming
leah i feel like
you were a good leader this week i think
your perseverance and your
attitude is second to none
so top three week three
brooklyn
leah
henley
phenomenal job good job kids go
celebrate
[Applause]
taya i'm impressed
dallas i'm tiny t
go join your friends in the lobby
good job tiny t
tatum
i think you're so talented
i think your mom and i believe in you
more than you believe in yourself
you're a good singer
you're a great dancer
i feel like you don't know it yet
belly are a dream to work with
a dream
i think you're a phenomenal dancer your
singing scares me
your audition wednesday night was rough
i have two phenomenal kids with two tiny
little weaknesses and i have to send one
of them home
based on that
i don't know what happened today
got a little tripped up
this is getting so competitive and
everything's so close that the little
things matter i think you're both gonna
be stars
no matter what happens here
[Music]